well that position consists of you know
that position has basically been routed
right in the December elections United
Russia Putin's party won about seventy
percent of the vote it now holds 300
seats in the parliament and Duma and
what this means is about newspapers and
the TV can stop referring to it as
United Russia and just you know call it
the party which is amazing you would
think that you know people who use the
term the party without qualifying which
party it is would would feel some you
know muscle of fear twitch in their
bodies when they do it i mean you know
stalin wasn't that long ago but now you
know it's the party so basically of it
you have a you know you have a one-party
system with a with a few kind of popular
distractions thrown in and any political
situation where a communists have to
coexist with sort of quasi nazi
chauvinists and they together have to
band with you know actual social
liberals just to cobble together some
sort of bizarre alliance of convenience
to provide anything resembling in a
position well then you know there is no
position it's it's the equivalent of you
know those are the Independent Party the
working families party and the greens
and you know and David Duke or something
of forming a coalition to you know to
provide quote unquote a position to the
you know the ruling party it's it
doesn't make any sense and if they get
any kind of power they will you know
they will fracture within seconds so
it's quite obvious that Russia at this
point is for all intents and purposes of
one party system Saturday
the union of the right forces was
basically a coalition put together to to
try to provide some sort of
counterweight to Putin's party United
Russia for the December elections and as
you know they haven't succeeded and part
of it is that there is no coherent a
position to put on some of it comes from
the right some of it comes from the left
some it comes from the extreme fringes
on both sides and an idea that you can
cobble together and you know alliance of
convenience from there and and have it
be you know have it be a coherent force
in politics or in policy is of course
laughable so at this point I think we'll
have to we'll have to consign the union
of the right forces to as you know the
Soviets used to say the bit in the trash
bin of history simply because well for
one thing it looks like half of the
parties in it our own United Russia's
payroll in fact one of you know one of
Putin's opponents sorry one of movoto's
opponents in the March second elections
Bogdanov has put together his own party
uh by being on the barrel of United
Russia so let's meditate on that for a
second you know obviously the United
Russia is throwing up some dummy parties
and dummy opponents to a to dilute the
sense that there is a real a position to
it and in a sense at this point there
isn't Kasparov you know whom I
personally admire um has never been able
to connect with the people because part
of just kind of seems like the you know
the right guy for the west to to hang
their hopes on and this is exactly the
kind of mistake that the West keeps
making over and over again by picking
various exiles to
you know to try to mount a positions to
totalitarian regimes and not that you
know cuz part of was a literal exile but
you know what you know what I mean you
have to pick people who are actually
popular you know on the streets and for
that you have to know the streets and
nobody in the West have been all that
interested in finding out